um i'll talk about david cameron in the
moment but just to talk about someone
who is still
very much a member of the government
first uh matt hancock
so he owns 15 of the shares in a firm
called topwood now that's a company
where his sister is a director it's also
approved as a supplier for the nhs
is that really acceptable well of course
the reason we know about this is that
matt hancock did exactly what
all ministers would do in this case
which is to declare that
interest and so he did the right thing
he's declared that
he's had no role whatsoever in any
procurement around this business so yes
there's nothing wrong
uh with ministers having financial
interests
provided they declare them in the
appropriate way
as long as you declare it you can do
whatever you want no
as long as you declare it and then have
no role obviously in any procurement
decisions around that company
that's the important thing here um you
know the important thing is
is much more how do ministers act and
conduct themselves in these situations
if there is a potential conflict
well the the thing they should do is
make sure they remove all of that
conflict by ensuring they have no role
whatsoever
in decisions surrounding such companies
but secondly declare it so there can be
no
perception that they might and so he's
done what you'd expect someone to do in
that case
you say there's no perception of a
conflict of interest because he's
declared it
you know i'm not suggesting that matt
hancock's broken the rules here
as you say he's followed the rules but
some people looking at this might think
that if a health secretary can
own a sizeable chunk of shares in a
company run by his sister
that is then a supplier for the
department which he is the head of
then it's the rules themselves that are
broken well i i'm not sure
actually that i would agree with that
obviously look ministers can move around
a lot
famously we tend not to spend
you know too long in one particular role
sometimes a
minister will be given a position and
may have a long-standing
financial interest that they therefore
need to declare i don't think that was
the case in in this one but that is
often
the case and so they declare it in the
usual way and then remove themselves
from any
decisions that uh that might affect
their own you know financial interest
and as far as
that's exactly what matt hancock did i
mean the reason we know about this the
reason is being talked about
is because he declared it and he did the
right thing yeah he did declare
i'm not saying that's not the you know
what he did but at the same time
you know can you not understand why some
people looking at this might be thinking
this looks pretty off shouldn't there be
more
distance in place shouldn't there be
more rules in place to try and make sure
that these conflicts of interest don't
happen whether or not they're declared
well look there's a lot of different
government uh what government inquiries
so the prime minister set
up uh nigel baldwin to look at the green
hill case in particular there's then
that's not looking at the matt hancock
case so is it no it won't but there's
also
uh simon greenshield's looking at the
issue of civil servants potentially
having second jobs to make sure that
there's no conflicts there and of course
then
there are several parliamentary
committees looking at this i think the
right thing to do is
for these reviews to go through their
process to conclude
uh to work out exactly what did and did
not happen and then yes
of course there may come a time uh after
that
uh when it's right to consider tweaks to
policy but fundamentally
i think that the uh systems we have in
place with ministers declaring interest
with the ministerial code and the focus
on that and how
ministers conduct themselves uh in
office is actually a pretty good one but
that's not to say that you couldn't make
tweaks or changes
and also there'll be a time and a place
for that after these reviews have
concluded
let's talk about the boardman review
shall we because i understand that it is
quite helpful for when you know
ministers like yourself do these rounds
that you can point towards the fact that
the you know the baldwin review has been
set up
at the same time though it's got no
power to sanction no statute or legal
force
and it's strictly limited to looking at
the green salt affair
i mean it sounds a bit toothless doesn't
it well no
i i think it's actually the right thing
to do because the you know the worst
thing
for ministers is to to say that they
think everything's okay and then
suddenly it turns out that there are
other details that emerge
and so the prime minister i think quite
rightly has said let's get to the bottom
of this
uh let's have uh a legal professional
who's a non-executive director at the
cabinet office
to really look at this don't they need
more powers this is the point i'm
getting at doesn't this review
need more powers if it's going to be
taken seriously well i don't think it
needs powers i think what it needs to do
is to get to the bottom of what happened
and then as i said if following that if
there's a a general view in parliament
that
um the rules around declaration of
ministers interests could be
uh changed slightly or if there's a view
that
uh rules around what ministers can do
when they leave office should be changed
slightly well then that's a policy
decision and that's something that can
be taken to the point but it doesn't
this review doesn't need
enforcement powers as such it just needs
to get to the bottom of what's happened
so will you
implement what the review recommends
then well the review is going to
establish
what happened uh in this particular case
i know what the review is going to do
but
will you commit to implementing what the
review well
i don't think the review is going to
make policy recommendations but of
course there are there are other
uh reviews going on in the park what's
the point of it
genuinely it there's no powers it's not
going to make policy recommendations
what's the point well because people are
raising questions uh about what happened
in this particular instance around
greens
both because there was a yeah we know
the questions well there was a civil
servant uh bill cruthers who
at one point was working for the civil
service and had a role
in greensville so that is something
that's being looked at
and obviously there's been a lot of
questions raised about david cameron's
contacts with ministers
so the purpose of the review is to
answer the questions
that people are asking um but it's not
really there to
prescribe policy so there are other
parliamentary committees
that are looking at this issue in the
round and i'm sure many of them will
make recommendations on policy and of
course government will always
look very carefully at what parliament
recommends in this space let's talk
about david cameron
are you comfortable with the way the
former prime minister has acted
well look he himself has said that with
hindsight probably would have been
better
if rather than texting ministers if he
had instead
written letters to set out his uh uh
his views uh more formally but i think
the the real
point is has he done anything wrong well
on the face of it uh no
but you know there's a review that's
going on we mustn't uh prejudge it you
don't think he's doing the thing right
well there are rules that say
the limit what a former minister or
former prime minister can do for a
period of two years
he meticulously observed those yes he
then took roles uh after that
did he exploit the rules this is the
thing it's it's like do you think that
he took advantage of rules that many
think well just two lakhs
well i don't think he took advantage of
any rules no he meticulously observed
the rules
there that he himself actually put in
place after
some concerns around lobbying a decade
ago he put in place these restrictions
on what ministers can do for a period of
uh
two years but look he himself has
conceded that with hindsight if he had
his time again
he wouldn't have texted rishi sunak and
wouldn't have texted others
he would instead have written through
formal channels but the big question is
what did then rishi sunak do having been
approached the answer is
you know he asked uh the question asked
people to look at this issue
the answer came back there was nothing
that could be done for this company uh
the company was
told we're not going to do anything at
all to help you and the company went
bust so
at the end of the day um did people give
any special favors to david cameron or
indeed to greensboro he answered that's
no
you worked quite closely with david
cameron when you press secretary for him
when he was leader of the opposition
given what you know about david cameron
do you think that he's acted in a sort
of calculated way here
or do you think frankly he's just been a
bit of an idiot
well i wouldn't uh ascribe to either of
those uh
definitions i i think look he he uh
abided by
uh the rules that he himself put in
place and so it didn't take any
uh roles for the period of two years
after leaving office
he's been out of office five years now
and he left office when he was still
quite young
and that's caught from the case now with
prime ministers and you can't begrudge
people
a chance to do a different career and
something different after they've
left that top job i think everybody
would accept that
but look uh in terms of did he do
anything wrong well like he himself
conceded that
the manner in which he approached yeah
rishi sunak on this particular issue
uh on behalf of a company that he was
working for by text
probably was ill-advised and probably he
should have done it
through a more formal route with a
letter uh through his private office
david cameron himself conceded that and
that he would do things differently
uh if he had his time again okay i'm
keen to move on now to
uh covid um nhs providers warning this
morning that it could take five years to
clear
the backlog caused by the pandemic how
concerned are you
well this is uh obviously an important
issue it's been a huge
endeavor that the nhs have been through
to try to deal with
kovid we've tried um apart from those
peak periods
uh the government has really tried to
encourage people
with other routine operations to to keep
coming in when they're
able to when when the nhs hasn't been at
those peak periods
obviously people have been anxious at
times and obviously at times when the
nhs has been particularly stressed
they've had it they found it less easy
to take forward those other
those other operations but i know that
this will be very high on
matt hancock's agenda as we emerge from
the
pandemic making sure that we can get on
top of those
uh routine operations that are obviously
so important and that have um
um life you know life consequences
themselves
um another issue that many people are
worried about at the minute is the
emergence of these new variants we know
about this
variant first discovered in india lots
of work being done to try and like track
exactly how much of a foothold it has in
the uk
and have you got the most up-to-date
figures on how many cases there are
um the last i think i saw there are
around 70 cases
but i think i've seen lots of different
numbers on different variants you'll
appreciate this quite a few
so it's a it's a fairly small number
at the moment but it is something that
we are watching
then i'm told that there's no evidence
at the moment that this
particular variant is uh able to
get around the vaccine for instance or
indeed that it's
necessarily more contagious than the
others
but we are looking at it it will be
studied we've got some of the best
genomic studies available in this
country we're very good at
genome sequencing four different
variants and that work is
uh is ongoing and obviously there's a
wider concern here
the biggest threat to everything that
we're doing at the moment is that at
some point
there will be a variant that manages to
evade the vaccine or
largely evade it so it is high on our
concerns which is why
well the vaccine rollout has been
incredibly successful with over
60 percent of the adult population now
vaccinated we continue to
to proceed with some caution as we come
out of lockdown um
i'm interested to know why india
isn't currently on the uk's red list
this is the list of companies where
you're either banned from coming into
the country or you have to quarantine
for 10 days in a hotel
so at the minute in india there are over
10 000 covered cases per million people
if you compare that to 3 000 in pakistan
just over 4 000 in bangladesh
pakistan and bangladesh are on the red
list
but india isn't can you reassure me that
this is science not politics at play
here given the prime minister's planning
a trip to india
look uh yes so the we have uh
an expert committee that uh that looks
at this and then
makes recommendations uh to the
transport secretary and matt hancock and
the
uh the group that make up the the covid
cabinet subcommittee they look very
closely at it and it's then discussed
more widely it is reviewed periodically
so you know roughly every
every 10 days or so they they look at
this if there's a need to do something
urgently they can do that
but they do periodically review variants
that are in other countries and the
approach that we should take
we should bear in mind that everybody
coming here needs to get a pre-departure
test and also test after arrival
so that's an approach that we take uh
that we take now but for those redless
countries obviously
quarantine is also required and i know
they're looking at reviewing this to
have a sort of
green amber and red approach to to
triage things more because
international traffic is going to become
a more important focal point as we come
out of lockdown
is it really a good idea for the prime
minister to be going to
india later this month when we know that
covered cases there
are surging i know there's a brexit
trade deal potentially riding on this
trip but surely public health has got to
come first
well public health does come first but
that doesn't mean that there should be
no visits at all for business purposes
and so
yes it's already the case people can't
go on holiday they can't travel at all
on holiday but for something like this i
think yes it is appropriate but look
absolutely
measures will be taken to ensure that
the visit is covered secure
that any uh staff and the entourage
attending with the prime
minister uh will obviously be in a
covert secure environment extra
precautions will be taken
but i think it is important that uh the
business and the
uh the the the the business of politics
if you like does
continue and doesn't stop uh doesn't
stop completely we just need to make
sure we take the right precautions
just finally the uk is hosting the cop
26 climate summit uh in glasgow in
november
big deal know how huge of course climate
change is
globally but also for this government as
well
some are saying it should be done
remotely how committed are you to make
sure it's done in person
well we think it should be done in
person physically and these are
there is a cop secretariat or a cop
bureau that ultimately makes these final
decisions but they do so
in a really very close cooperation with
the host country
and we delayed it obviously last year
because we wanted it to happen in person
i think it's much more effective if it
does happen in person that's absolutely
our intention there may be
components um of it that are um
part virtual that some people attend
virtually but we think for the main
leader summit we should try and make
sure that it happens in person and
that's our intention